hi everyone I'm David Griffin and now
Michael Medina here to bring you this
week's review of arrow season 2 episode
5 the League of Assassins man huge huge
episode this week it's more horror feels
more exciting things going on I mean I
don't know where to start I that's the
one thing about this this season is that
it's just been it's so good it's been
like the energy level has just been up
and it's just it keeps going keeps
hitting you in the face you know all
these different characters that they're
introducing expanding the universe and
stuff it has not disappointed me so far
that doesn't know what to do I mean
every week there's just something new I
mean this week where I guess let's jump
into it I kind of skipping around here a
little bit all over the place that's
okay it's episodes all over the place
well dr. Ivo yeah that was really cool
the Amazo boat of course they teased it
a few weeks back and then we saw you
know the Amazo boat again today and I
remember just thinking like when are we
gonna see him at some point we have to
and we finally do we finally get
introduced any and he he pulls Sarah in
the back and stuff and just yeah I guess
he's trying to recruit her help like
save the human race like perfect
humanities we know Amazo has the whole
Android who can what absorb other
people's power shaman shaman uh young
justice women just like the animated
series uh you know go check that on
netflix we haven't seen that it's
awesome stuff and then he's here I mean
I don't know we're gonna see this like
Andrew who can defeat all the Justice
League but I wonder what he's trying to
do I think I think so far they have yet
to let me down so right or they'll
probably do that character justice for
sure and of course got to go into the
fact that we're seeing more of the
League of Assassins which is title is
this is I mean you have all the
characters in here this is a story for
Sarah basically when we get her a little
bit of her or her backstory base yeah
little river backstory I want to know
what's what's up that's what's up with
reishi al Ghul once or there's some
personal beef I mean there be with her
like what did she do I wonder what it
seems to me like she was um his golden
child yeah we kind of took her under his
wing or the fact that she leaves the
League of Assassins which is something
but i only do by death basically and
stuff obviously didn't sit too well with
him or any of the other you know assess
and so they basically are coming after
her going to Starling Starling city and
threatening her dad and everything so
cuz they had the whole when they had a
whole discussion with the fight and the
guy said you know the daughter of Ra's
al Ghul must return home was like is
that like he's on her
figuratively or is that Thalia but I
assume it's her yeah I'm kinda hoping
Thalia Damien might show that's too much
got me thinking about the college
departure angle might actually work is
given the fact that you know he clearly
has some kind of a connection with
racial address so I'd imagine it
wouldn't be too far-fetched to think
that maybe Thalia might be a little
jealous maybe we'll sear yeah I mean
it's good i mean again you know if there
is a negative i wish we could see Diggle
do some work I mean I can't complain
because episode was awesome there's so
much cool stuff in here but diggle's is
kind of like hanging out just chillin I
want to see him do a little more yeah I
feel like that's a problem that I've had
the last couple seasons actually I get
you know the first season want to kind
of like establish a character named
right but now he's been you know he's
been through countless mission yeah just
whatever helping Oliver out and stuff
but the guys fit right yes big days
working on I'd like to see him out in
the field more doing a little bit yes
something anything so I guess one of the
other revelations we have is we now know
that Malcolm Merlyn was with the League
of Assassins imeem he had the same
outfit on the same attire so who the
league everyone sense so I wonder what I
mean are we gonna get the Christopher
Nolan story in the sense that race is
trying to you know destroy all these
cities were at their peak am I people
are gonna go a different mythology at
different stories as a new a different
writing team hopefully they're not going
to follow christopher nolan story like I
wonder what race is what is gold are we
gonna see race yeah that's uh I don't
know I'd like to think that we will at
some point but I think right now I think
we'd have a better chance at seeing
Talia right yeah Holly them and that
would be good too i mean and again and
this episode has had so much things I
mean of course Laurel still has a little
drug issue going on I mean I got a
little romance going on that was just
anything in the hallway when she tried
to kiss him I wasn't I didn't see that
coming so let's not forget that Sarah
finally reveals herself to her yes as
you know like in previous episode that
was something that was really difficult
for her to do and we see her do it
obviously it was tough it was it was
very heartbreaking run at the end of the
episode she basically you know she had
to go separate they had to go their
separate ways and kind of had to leave
her dad with the responsibility of
keeping this a secret from Laurel yeah i
mean i love the scene when his dad
saying like how do you live like that
you know i mean it's just the mean how
do you tell all these lies i mean it's
it is kind of going back to ollie I mean
he's a little bit hypocritical talking
to his mom about mommy to come clean
we're going to love you no matter what
it's like man you're keeping like the
biggest
secret absolutely anyone absolutely and
your mom crap for not coming out and
confessing whatever it is that she's
she's hiding but that that's that's the
problem right there isn't it though you
know how do you do that how do you you
know open yourself up to your family and
risk them their lives based right right
so I mean this is sets in motion so many
different things that we had brother
blood was revealed last week we know the
flash is going to be coming to toe in
the future but i'd imagine later later
maybe half 2nd half next Elias I liked
it like you were point I really like
that they're not staying on just one yes
they're moving constantly moving the
show constable there hasn't been a
filler episode yet it's five episodes
yeah and I like that it's not like a
brother blood season and that's no
regrets one build their season of yeah
trickling in all these characters but
you sing like you know we just saw you
know Black Canary his last as I'm sure
she'll go away at some point I'm sure
she's gonna come back to you yeah Yello
brother a little bit of everything so
now you know they're gonna tease amazing
so yeah yeah i mean the season just
keeps getting better and better I mean
you know this is micah I know you're
loving it loving this season I've yet to
be disappointed it's great I mean I want
to hear your theories I mean there's so
much going especially with League of
Assassins racial google is just so much
that I mean the series can go anywhere
so you know so like please like you know
that was what we thought of this week's
episode you know as always come chat
with us share your thoughts with us I
think your comms when the errors you can
find us on our website well said this
YouTube channel just think hero Pro also
you know we're on twitter i won't come
chat with dennis michael and myself
figure out what's going on like talked
about TV shows movies whatever it is
you're into that's at think hero i'm at
griffin de and i'm at mr. michael Alexis
and also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans
you